>> Greg: IT'S A STORY THAT
MAKES YOU ANGER EVERY DAY.
DOCUMENT SHOW OFFICIAL SUGGESTED
THAT THE PARKLAND MADMAN BE
COMMITTED A YEAR OR SO AGO WHICH
COULD HAVE PREVENTED HIS MURDER
SPREE.
DEPUTY SCOT PETERSON WAS ONE OF
THOSE OFFICIALS SO THE SAME
DEPUTY THAT SHERIFF ISRAEL
THROUGH UNDER THE BUS FOR NOT
CONFRONTING THE SHOOTER HAD
ACTUALLY TRIED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING LONG BEFORE THAT.
WHERE WAS HIS BOSS THEN?
GETTING HIS FACE PAINTED ON
CARS?
WHY WASN'T THE KILLER NABBED
DESPITE ALL THE RED FLAGS?
WHAT WE SAW WAS A COUNTY THEY
DID HALF A RIGHT THING.
THEY SAW SOMETHING, DID NOTHING.
IT'S AN UGLY LESSON.
HALF A RIGHT THING CAN BE WORSE
THAN ONE WHOLE WRONG THING OR
PRETENDS TO BE PROGRESS AND THAT
PREVENTS REAL SOLUTIONS.
EXAMPLE: MORE LENIENT SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE HAS BEEN HAILED AS
PROGRESS.
BUT IS IT?
NATIONAL REVIEWS DAVID FRENCH
REPORTS IN 2013 THE
BROWARD COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD
AGREED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
LIMIT ON-CAMPUS ARRESTS.
TO THAT EFFECT THIS CASE?
COULD BE.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT WENT WRONG, AND
IT'S TIME TO WRITE IT.
FIRST, FIRE ISRAEL.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN A MORE
INCOMPETENT BOOB IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
LET'S CREATE A DATABASE FOR SICK
PEOPLE TAGGED IN CIVIL COURT
BASED ON TESTIMONY BY OFFICIALS,
TEACHERS, AND SO ON.
IF YOU ARE ON THAT LIST, THEN NO
GUNS.
THAT'S CALLED A PLAN.
IT'S NOT HALF THE PLAN.
IT'S ONE THAT WOULD SAVE 17 --
WOULD HAVE SAVED 17 LIVES.
JESSE, THIS ARTICLE, CAN'T
REMEMBER IF IT WAS IN "THE
FEDERALIST" OR NATIONAL REVIEW
ABOUT HOW THEY DECIDED NOT TO
SEND KIDS, TO GET INVOLVED WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT KIDS TO GO TO
JAIL.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME TALK THAT
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN THE REASON
WHY THIS GUY GOT THROUGH.
>> Jesse: IT COULD HAVE BEEN.
STARTED UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO UNFAIRLY TARGET MINORITY
STUDENTS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM WERE
GETTING ARRESTED.
IT WAS HAVING REPERCUSSIONS ON
GOING TO COLLEGE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE
SUCH AN EGREGIOUS CASE OF
MISBEHAVIOR AND DANGEROUS
BEHAVIOR FROM THIS KID.
IF YOU ARE CUTTING YOURSELF, IF
YOU ARE THING I WANT TO KILL
SOMEONE WITH A GUN, IF YOU'RE
THROWING A MOTHER UP AGAINST THE
WALL.
IF YOU ARE DOING ALL SORTS OF
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS IN THE EVENT
TRIED TO BE CIVILLY COMMITTED
TWICE, THE FBI HAS BEEN TIPPED
OFF TWO OR THREE TIMES, THE
POLICE HAVE VISITED YOUR HOUSE
ALMOST 30 TO 50 TIMES.
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE WERE LAWS
AND MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO
PREVENT THIS.
EVERYTHING ON THE STATE, LOCAL,
AND FEDERAL LEVEL BROKE DOWN.
IF YOU LOOK AT A GUY LIKE ISRAEL
WHO WAS TAKEN ZERO
RESPONSIBILITY.
CARES MORE ABOUT POLITICS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
APPARENTLY HE DOESN'T DISCUSS
CRIME.
HE'S ABOUT PARADE ROUTES AND
WHETHER HE CAN GET UP WHICH ARE
WITH POLITICIANS.
HE IS NOT LIKED AMONG PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND THERE.
SO HE BROUGHT ALL HIS FUNKY
FRIENDS FROM SOFTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACK PRESENT WITH
THEM IN CHARGE OF PLACES LIKE
PARKLAND.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
POOR TRAINING, POOR REACTION
TIME.
THE SHOOTING IN MARYLAND TODAY
IS INTERESTING BECAUSE IT WAS
DONE WITH A PISTOL.
AN ARMED PERSON WAS AT THE
SCHOOL AND NEUTRALIZE THE
SHOOTER BEFORE HE COULD DO
ANYMORE DAMAGE.
LIFE KIND OF GIVES YOU LESSONS.
TO NOT LOOK AT THESE LESSONS IS
JUST NOT THE RIGHT THING.
YOU'RE NOT HEARING THE MEDIA
TALK ABOUT AN AR-15.
YOU ARE NOT HEARING THE MEDIA
TALK ABOUT SCHOOL SAFETY
SOLUTIONS WITH ARMED SECURITY
GUARDS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT
THEIR ANTI-NRA NARRATIVE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
MARYLAND, AS A SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: DANA, THE SHERIFF IS
STILL THERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO DO TO LOSE
YOUR JOB IN FLORIDA?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW EITHER.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Dana: COULD BE A RECALL,
YOU WOULD IMAGINE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I DO THINK IT'S PRETTY
INTERESTING, THE DEPUTY WHO TOOK
SO MUCH GRIEF.
THE DEPUTY'S LAWYER SAID
REPEATEDLY THERE IS MORE TO THIS
STORY.
THEY WERE HOLDING BACK.
>> Greg: THAT TICKS ME OFF
ABOUT ISRAEL EVEN MORE.
IF THIS GUY PETERSON WAS TRYING
TO GET THIS GUY OUT OF THE
SCHOOL AND IF ISRAEL DID NOTHING
AT AND THEN THREW HIM UNDER THE
BUS, WHAT A LOATHSOME CREATURE.
TERRIBLE.
>> Kimberly: HERE'S A PROBLEM.
SO MANY MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
THAT IT REALLY GOES BACK TO EVEN
IN 2016 THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT AWAY NIKOLAS CRUZ AND PUT
HIM IN VOLUNTARY CONFINEMENT.
THEY DON'T TAKE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN THEY KNOW
THAT HE IS MENTALLY DANGEROUS
AND UNFIT PERSON, THERE BY
CREATING A FURTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK THAT MANIFESTED IN THE
SHOOTING AND LOSS OF LIFE.
THAT'S A PROBLEM, COMPOUNDED BY
THE LACK OF LEADERSHIP BY
SHERIFF ISRAEL, BY THE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE SCENE.
A NUMBER OF MISSTEPS THAT
RESULTED IN A FURTHER ADDITIONAL
LOSS OF LIFE.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, IT'S SORT OF
A TEXTBOOK EXAMPLE OF HOW
EVERYTHING SORT OF WENT WRONG
AND CONVERGED TOGETHER TO THIS
PERFECT, HORRIFIC STORM OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE GUN.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
STEPS AND IF YOU MISS THOSE
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE, IT'S GOING
TO REPEAT ITSELF.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE WEAPONS.
WHETHER IT'S BOMBS, DETONATOR
CAPS, PRESSURE COOKERS, WHETHER
IT'S THE CAR YOU DRIVE INTO A
CROWD, ANYTHING LIKE THAT, IF
THE INTENTION IS THERE AND YOU
DO NOT SEE THAT THAT PERSON IS A
THREAT, PICKING UP THE SIGNALS
INCLUDES AN INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING TO PREVENT IT, THAT'S
THE FIRST STEP.
IF YOU GET TO THAT PIECE, YOU
DON'T EVEN GET TO THE GUN.
>> Greg: JUAN, NOT TO KNOCK
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT THE ACTS
PREVENTED.
THERE ARE THINGS LIKE THIS EVERY
DAY THAT HAVE PROBABLY BEEN
STOPPED.
IN THIS CASE, THIS MAY BE THE
MOST PREVENTABLE GUNS.
I THINK I'VE EVER SEEN.
VEGAS, I WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO
STOP THAT.
>> Kimberly: THEY WERE CALLED
29 TIMES, THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
>> Juan: I FEEL LIKE I AM IN
SUPPORT OF GUN CONTROL AND I
LOOK AT THE POLLS, I SEE MOST
AMERICANS, MOST GUN OWNERS ARE
IN SUPPORT SOME KIND OF
INCREASING BACKGROUND CHECKS,
NOT ALLOWING WEAPONS OF WAR TO
BE SOLD AND THE LIKE.
PEOPLE WANT TO CLOSE GUN SHOW
LOOPHOLES AND THE LIKE.
I'M LISTENING I THINK THE NRA
LINE IS OH, GOSH, YOU KNOW.
THIS IS THE RESULT OF INADEQUATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ACCESS TO GUNS.
BUT I THINK ACCESS TO GUNS IS A
PART OF THE EQUATION.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY THE CIVIL
TAG IN A COURT WOULD DO THAT.
IF YOU SAID OKAY, THE SCHOOL
OFFICIALS AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND WHOEVER, POLICE, KNEW THIS
GUY WAS A PROBLEM.
THAT WOULD -- HE CAN'T GET A
GUN.
THERE'S NO PLACE TO PUT THIS GUY
YET.
EXCEPT AN INSTITUTION.
>> Juan: YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE SHERIFF WHO HAS HIS OWN
PROBLEMS.
I THINK IN FACT AS YOU SAY, THE
DEPUTY ON THE SCHOOL GROUNDS HAD
SAID THIS GUY SHOULD BE PUT AWAY
UNDER THE BAKER ACT OR WHATEVER.
AND THEN YOU GET THE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THERAPISTS SAYING
NO, IT WASN'T THE SHERIFF WAS
SAID NO.
IT WAS THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMMUNITY THAT SAID NO AT THE
TIME TO THIS PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO SEE
THOSE RECORDS.
BUT I WILL NOTE I WAS READING
ABOUT THIS GUY, ISRAEL, THE
SHERIFF.
HE IS SO INTERESTING.
HE WAS A REPUBLICAN WHO PUSHED
TO BE A DEMOCRAT AND HE IS A
CRONY OF ROGER STONE.